[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce lundi 7 octobre
bienvenue pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv à 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce journal il a
entamé sa mutation le technocentre
renault à guyancourt a lancé son
programme de rénovation en cinq ans les
espaces de travail seront intégralement
transformé pour les rendre plus moderne
et plus énergétiques visite des lieux
une après midi de rencontres et
d'échangés consacré aux aidants elle se
déroulait aujourd'hui au centre
hospitalier de plaisir au lendemain de
la journée nationale dédiée
retour sur l'événement et sur le travail
mené dans l'établissement de santé saint
quentinois
et puis 6 sur 6 pour le football club de
versailles qui n'en finit plus de gagner
dans le championnat de nationale 3
victoires 3 0 contre torcy samedi ce
résultat et bien d'autres encore à
retrouver dans cette édition
et puis à suivre tout à l'heure
l'association coeur de bouchons
interview avec cette association qui en
ce moment besoin de bénévoles
le technocentre renault de guyancourt en
rénovation il est entré dans une phase
de travaux plusieurs phases de travaux
qui vont durer jusqu'en 2023 un
programme visant à moderniser lé bureau
améliorer la consommation énergétique et
le confort des quelques 10000 salariés
sur le site
un reportage de nicolas d'andré de
margaux du roi les premiers travaux ont
débuté en juillet 2010 9 plusieurs
parties du technocentre renault de
guyancourt vont connaître une rénovation
une réorganisation des espaces de
travail et une amélioration des systèmes
énergétiques des infrastructures datant
de 1998
vous êtes ici donc sur la première zone
qui a été curé donc comme vous voyez on
enlève tout tout est trié par type de
produit pour être envoyés en recyclage
après donc nous avons complètement vidé
le plateau de tous ses équipements de
tous est fluide et tout va être remis à
neuf
ces équipements qui sont là ont
quasiment 20 ans pour la plupart pour un
différend les a changés mais sinon en
moyenne ils ont 20 ans donc là on remet
tout à neuf c'est un nouvel immeuble en
train de construire on ne garde que la
peau extérieure
ces transformations c'est le programme
pcr pour efficience du technocentre
renault du nouveau mobilier des espaces
de réunion du matériel neuf
des outils actuellement en test par des
collaborateurs
engagé sur cette question c'est un
verrou à s'y dévouent électriques pour
que chacun puisse le régler comme il
veut et travailler debout souvent en fin
de journée on voit que les gens se
lèvent mettre leurs bureaux de boue ils
travaillent debout au plus haut plus
haut et tous les postes sont équipés
d'écrans avec des bras multifonctions
qui permettent de le mettre dans tous
les sens au coeur de cette réflexion
lancée en 2015 le travail collaboratif à
travers des espaces de travail et de
détente comme ce work in qu'a fait ce
qu'on veut c'est effectivement donner un
maximum de confort pour tous qui est
l'environnement physique pour que le
salarié se met dans les meilleures
conditions pour travailler
l'objectif de cette opération c'est de
décloisonner et de d'améliorer la
convivialité la collaboration entre les
personnes et les mettre plus dans la
lumière
la fin des travaux est prévue pour 2023
à noter aussi la construction d'odyssée
un nouveau bâtiment en bois installés
sur le site
mais l'actualité c'est également cette
manifestation des anti pma hier à paris
21 une association pour la plupart
catholiques ont défilé ce dimanche dans
les rues de la capitale et mobilisations
contre l'ouverture de la procréation
médicalement assistée aux femmes seules
ou en couple lesbien
c'est l'article 1 de la loi bioéthique
qui a été adopté en première lecture par
les députés
un défilé et une guerre et des chiffres
le cortège a rassemblé soixante quatorze
mille cinq cents personnes selon un
organisme de comptage indépendant six
cent mille selon les organisateurs on
rappelle que la mobilisation pour le
mariage pour tous avait rassemblé 1,4
million de personnes d'après les
associations écouter jean frédéric
poisson interrogé par marylène yapi
chinois ne peut pas demander à l'état de
mentir un point tel que on disait un
enfant officiellement dans son état
civil
mon garçon dit ma fille je n'avais pas
de père parce que ça n'est pas vrai ça
n'est pas vrai donc d'inscrire sa sous
l'autorité de l'état est un mensonge
d'état est si grave
je pense que les les événements qui se
sont déroulés l'année bicig à
l'assemblée nationale
toute la semaine dernière ont contribué
à alimenter cette mobilisation dimension
que un beau succès en tout cas et je
suis content de voir que petit à petit
on comprend tous les enjeux de ce texte
au delà simplement de l'accueil des
enfants parole
des couples homosexuels de femmes enfin
ça m'a surpris je ne pensais pas qu'il y
aurait in her autant devant que ça mais
on verra bien ce que ça donne par la
suite mais il faut s'attendre
effectivement de très grosse
mobilisation à nouveau dans démenti bien
cinq autres dates de rassemblements sont
prévus dont la prochaine le 1er décembre
et sur le sujet de la pma vous pouvez
retrouver à notre reportage un
témoignage une famille homoparentale
c'est sur notre site internet et des 78
points comme jean frédéric poisson qui
ne siège plus au sein de la majorité du
maire de rambouillet marc robert ce
dernier vient d'annoncer qu'il ne
briguerait pas de second mandat à la
tête de la municipalité du sud yvelines
marc robert avait été élu aux élections
municipales de 2014 succédant à gérard
larcher le maire qui ira au bout de son
mandat souhaite s'arrêter pour raisons
de santé
c'est l'adjointe véronique matillon qui
a été désigné pour mener la liste de la
majorité au prochain scrutin en mars
2020 l'ancien adjoint schyle gîte
schmitt conduire à lui une liste la
république en marge dans l'opposition
l'écologiste david jutier sera également
candidat à aulnay sur mauldre commune de
1100 habitants voter ce dimanche
deuxième élection anticipée en trois ans
en suite à des désaccords au sein de la
majorité le maire sortant jean
christophe charbit a été reconduit pour
cinq mois il devance de quatre voix
seulement son adversaire michel contest
ancien adjoint
[Musique]
ils sont 11 millions à être considéré
comme aidant en france il hier dimanche
une journée nationale leur a été
consacré pour les soutenir les
reconnaître et informer davantage sur ce
statut événement suivi cet après midi
avec une journée dédiée au centre
hospitalier de plaisir elle s'est
achevée à 17 heures et elle sort tout
juste de cet événement est le docteur
karim abou le cours yahoo ni bonsoir est
également vilma bora trophe mon sport
vous êtes ce cadre de santé à l'hôpital
de jour psycho gériatre gériatrie pardon
et à l'accueil de jour au centre
hospitalier déjà pour commencer sur
cette thématique des aidants si on peut
rappeler la définition de ce qu'est un
aidant à partir de quel moment et ont
considéré comme un aidant les dents est
un parent proche qui peut être ou le
conjoint ou l'enfant si la personne n'a
pas de parents profs ça peut être un
voisin qui qui au quotidien donc avec
cette personne qui a des troubles de
mémoire les dents qu'on appelle les
dents familiaux sont vraiment très
importants puisqu'il nous apporte
beaucoup d'informations et
et on partage aussi avec eux et on
essaie de les aider dans leurs côtés
dans notre quotidien par des formations
par des des avis parce qu'ils arrivent à
un moment donné où ils sont épuisés ils
ne savent plus où s'orienter par moments
ils sont vraiment fatiguées
donc voilà nous avons une offre de soins
quoi qu'à l'hôpital de plaisir donc si
l'on les hôpitaux de jour de stimulation
cognitive et il ya les deux accueils de
jour de mes rentes et le galion où on
peut également en fonction de
l'évolution de la maladie orienté s'est
facilement l'occasion d'en reparler
juste après on précise juste que ce
statut aussi des aidants est de plus en
plus reconnue notamment avec de récentes
annonces du gouvernement un plan et donc
avec qui va voir le jour avec cette
mesure phare la mise en place d'un congé
rémunéré pour ces personnes pourquoi
organiser cette journée aujourd'hui
alors c'est sûr ils rentrent dans le
cadre de la journée nationale pour nous
c'est une première fois parce que des
puits au moment nous sommes très porté
sur toutes les aides qu'on peut apporter
aux aidants est donc là on avait
organisé chaque deux ans à peu près des
journées alzheimer à un plus large
spectre avec des professionnels des
partenaires de département
mais là on a voulu faire vraiment un
moment de partage avec eux parce que
nous avons des programmes d'éducation
thérapeutique qui sont aussi depuis
trois quatre ans on s'est tourné vers
cette problématique des l'accompagnement
des cédants elles se déroulent et
comment ces journées quel était le
programme de l'après-midi alors la
preuve le programme ça a été d'abord
l'ouverture avec un mot de directeur de
centre hospitalier des plaisirs et après
donc des invités dont call ars qui nous
soutient de ce projet d'éducation
thérapeutique depuis trois quatre ans
maintenant et aussi des stands pour
montrer le travail de toute une équipe
pluridisciplinaire avec des partenaires
aussi des villes et une présentation sur
quelque chose qui pour nous est assez
innovant c'est à dire comment travailler
auprès des
les aidants avec des méthodes
pédagogiques innovantes comme la méthode
montessori adaptée à la personne âgée
non c'est une thématique on l'a compris
sur lesquels vous travaillez au centre
hospitalier de plaisir docteur beaucoup
ria uni notamment au sein d'une filière
psychogériatrie se sent tout à fait
alors nous avons une filière a lancé la
consultation dans la filière tic
gériatrique il ya la consultation
mémoire
une fois la consultation réalisée il ya
des tests psychométriques qui sont
réalisés par les neuropsychologues et
après des consultations de retour
de là il ya une orientation de cette de
la personne qui présente des troubles
cognitifs soit en hôpital de jour pour
une simulation cognitif cd v alors qui
se déroule sur une période de 14 mois
renouvelable quatre mois et puis après
suivie de consultations
si la pathologie et évoluer donc là on
les oriente vers les accueils de jour
d'accord et puis bien sûr en parallèle
il ya des groupes de paroles d'il ya une
prise en charge avec la psychologue qui
peut suivre les aidants qui peut suivre
également le patient lui-même et tous
les plus les partenaires extérieurs
parce que nous avons également quand on
a des problématiques ont fait appel à
l'équipe et qui peut l'équipe mobile
extra hospitalière qui est le réseau
répit donc qui nous aide également
énormément parce qu'il a une vue à
l'extérieur et au domicile et aussi on
termine avec ça aide aux aidants qui est
un programme d'éducation thérapeutique
subventionné par l' agence régionale de
santé vous en parliez tout à l'heure il
me doit être verte est donc ce programme
nous avons commencé un 2016 c'est à dès
2015 toute l'équipe a été formé et
préparé à créer des séances d'éducation
thérapeutique et en 2016 avec la rs on a
fait une grande présentation et elle a
été porteuse de notre projet pour des
demandes d'autorisation est aussi
financement et donc aux quatre ans des
autorisations et des financements qui
vont s'achever début 2020 donc dans
lequel on fait une évaluation
quadriennale donc moi c'était très
important qu'on puisse être à l'écouté
des aidants aussi pour évaluer notre
programme est donc dans la filière
vont donc toutes les équipes de des
filières qui participe depuis
l'hospitalisation complète l'hôpital des
jongles les accueille des gens et toute
une politique de l'hôpital aussi à
mettre en avant l'éducation
thérapeutique vingtaine des formations
étaient aurait présentation merci à vous
deux on arrive à la fin de cette
autorité petit mois est rapidement nous
avons ce qui nous vend chez nous c'est
que nous avons eu les dents qui est
ressources
oui donc qui a bénéficié de la formation
et maintenant il est parti il participe
avec l'équipe et qui donne également des
formations pour les autres étant merci à
vous deux karima docteur karim aboul
cours yahoo ni et villemin borat rohff
d'être venu de parler de cette
thématique je précise jusqu'à l'entrée
dans village se déroulera aussi sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
il est prévu ce samedi c'est le deuxième
de ce nom vous retrouvez toutes les
informations sur le site internet de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 15 ans que la
ville de montigny le bretonneux organise
cet événement c'est la semaine du
handicap jusqu'à dimanche de nombreux
temps forts seront au programme de cette
16e édition ateliers de sensibilisation
course interreliés entreprises forum
andy recrutement la semaine qui se
clôturera le week-end au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin où vous pourrez
ramener à des bouchons sans modération
cette association gère justement la
récolte de bouchons dans toute la france
et aussi dans le département des
yvelines ses choeurs de bouchons à des
bouchons qui servent ensuite à
l'acquisition d'équipements spécifiques
pour les personnes handicapées on en
parle avec son président sébastien de
rue bonsoir ça alors vous venez en
plateau ce soir pour nous parler des
bénévoles puisqu'il y avait un manque de
bénévoles en tout cas vous êtes à la
recherche en ce monde de bénévoles c'est
ça fait le plus dur dans l'association
s'est trouvé des bénévoles qui viennent
participer au tri des bouchons sur les
différents locaux où on est installé
mais s'il n'y a pas une crise du
bénévolat dans le mouvement associatif
en général à votre a besoin de manière
générale oui je pense effectivement
c'est là le plus difficile que pour
qu'ils sont ils sont primordiaux pardon
ses bénévoles pour votre association
parce qu'on a besoin énormément de
personnes qui viennent pour pour trier
pour collecter les bouchons et qui
viennent participer justement à toute
action qui est mise en place avant même
de pouvoir aller à l'action finale qui
est acheté du matériel
mais quelles sont leurs missions du
saumon
c'est la collecte le tri soit la
collecte des bouchons soit le tri des
bouchons c'est vraiment suivant les gens
le temps qu'ils sont disponibles qui met
à disposition de l'association qui peut
devenir bénévole de votre association
tout le monde peut devenir bénévole
comment on fait pour devenir bénévole à
il suffit d'aller sur le site internet
de l'association bouchons franciliens
point fr ou coeur de bouchons par fr et
il y aura toutes les informations et les
liens pour pour nous contacter alors ça
de ça nécessite combien de temps on sait
que ça peut être un frein à l'engagement
dans le bénévolat le temps que ça
nécessite par semaine combien de temps
d'engagement pour votre association n'y
a pas d'engagement chacun est libre de
faire comme il veut ça peut être
quelques heures par jour quelques heures
par semaine quelques heures par mois
chacun vient quand il veut comme il veut
il n'y a pas d'engagement et vous l'avez
dit le but c'est de participer à cette
collecte au tri de ces bouchons et aussi
de participer au financement de
plusieurs actions en faveur en faveur
des personnes handicapées
qu'est-ce que ça finances concrètement
ce cette récolte feutry le bush alors le
tri des bouchons donc déjà c'est
important c'est que 100% de cet argent
va être distribué pour l'achat de
matériel que ce soit du fauteuil roulant
soit l'aménagement de véhicules
ce soit l'aménagement de la salle de
bains veut tous qu'ils aient accès à la
mobilité de la personne handicapée
il ya plusieurs missions l'association
est présente partout en france il ya une
implantation dans les yvelines depuis
quelques mois depuis un an c'est ça
alors oui la situation présente et il ya
d'autres associations qui existent mais
notre association est présente depuis un
an et en ces temps un petit peu sur plus
que les yvelines d'ailleurs la suite
pour vous c'est primordial d'avoir ces
bénévoles pour la suite de l'association
c'est l'essentiel oui effectivement
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme actualité là
pour votre association prochainement
prochainement basse et du tri beaucoup
de tri en fête en perspective parce
qu'on a des collègues qui s'agrandissent
énormément
donc là il faut vraiment qu'on est
beaucoup beaucoup de bénévoles pour nous
aider à trier merci beaucoup d'être
patient plateau pour lancer cet appel
sébastien de rue il ya le site de
l'association à qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran pour vous joindrez pour pourquoi
pas rejoindre cette équipe de bénévoles
de l'association coeur de bouchons merci
à la dette repasser en plateau
[Musique]
connaissez vous l'histoire de votre
maison le parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse s'est donné
une année pour répertorier les anciennes
résidences de villégiature
gwenaëlle saintilan est parti sur la
trace de ces maisons de campagne
regarder elles sont ancrées dans les
villages du parc naturel elle s'entoure
de jardin de balcons de ferronnerie
travailler et affiche d'élégantes
silhouette
ce sont les résidences de villégiature
donc la villégiature c'est une pratique
qui est très ancienne en fait il remonte
aux romains les roamad les villas
romaines par exemple à pompéi ou même à
rome donc les romains riches comme pline
l'ancien par exemple opine le jeune
avait des villages des villes à ce
qu'ils appelaient les villas c'est à
dire des maisons de villégiature dans
lesquelles ils allaient pour un séjour
relativement long ce qui distingue la on
parle bien de villégiature et pas de
tourisme
la villégiature c'est donc un séjour à
la campagne dans une propriété pour y
trouver le repos le bonheur et pratiquer
des loisirs intellectuelle lecture
musique ou autres avec le plus souvent
un jardin pour y cultiver ses produits
au 19e siècle la villégiature devient
également un mode de vie c'est pas la
vie en ville ou
on a des soirées chics là on vit
simplement on reçoit ses amis ont fait
des jeux on joue aux cartes on joue au
billard la salle de billard est un des
attributs de la villégiature
et puis on profite de la vue aussi parce
que très souvent ces maisons de
villégiature
elles sont situées en haut d'une colline
où
au bord d'une rivière enfin en haut
d'une rivière sur les coteaux d'une
rivière pour recenser ces villes là le
parc réalise des inventaires en
collaboration avec le service patrimoine
et inventaires de la région ile de
france
il identifie les différentes communes et
bâtiment a répertorié ensuite les
équipes partent sur le terrain pour
faire des observations et des relevés
plus précis ces maisons ont beaucoup de
points communs architecturaux et malgré
tout il existe beaucoup de variété de
formes et de matériaux
alors elles sont ici c'est vraiment
particulier parce que la meulière est
partout elles sont en meulière mais
assorti de briques assorti de céramique
de couleur c'est relativement sobre
quand même ya des maisons de
villégiature à la même époque en bord de
mer par exemple il ya des maisons de
villégiature balnéaire qui sont beaucoup
plus pittoresques avec beaucoup plus de
de décor avec des des fermes apparente à
jour et du bois ici c'est une
architecture relativement sobre une fois
les inventaires terminée ils seront
ensuite publiées sur le site du parc est
accessible à tous chacun pourra ainsi en
savoir un peu plus sur l'histoire de sa
maison et ainsi mieux respecter
l'histoire du bâti elle le sport deux
semaines avant l'ouverture de l'open de
france de golf à saint quentin en
yvelines le monde de la petite balle
blanche se retrouvait à la golf
expérience se déroulait à lille de
loisirs ce samedi des animations de 14
heures jusqu'à minuit
retour sur l'événement avec marilyn yapi
chine en avant après
ça y est babet connaît la position
parfaite pour driver avec trois mois
d'essai à son actif elle a décidé de
persévérer et profite d'un bilan
personnalisé proposé lors de cette golf
expérience la posture l'appui sur les
talons donc ça c'est important
et le relâchement des bras tout
l'après-midi le blue green de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
proposer des animations gratuites pour
s'initier ou se perfectionner à l'art du
golfe à l'aide de plusieurs ateliers à
trois ateliers qui permettent aux
débutants de prendre un club pour la
première fois en main donc à travers le
petit glas proches ou derrière moi le
practice et une fois qu'ils ont validé
ces ateliers bas ils peuvent démarrer
tout de suite sur un sur un parcours de
trois trous ou là ils sont accompagnés
par un golfeur
après la ryder cup place à l'open de
france l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines souhaite faire une belle
place ou golf et le démocratiser
l'objectif pour 50 ans est très clair
c'est de faire découvrir le golf pour
tous montrés en fait démystifier un peu
l'idée reçue que le golf est pour une
élite qu'il faut vraiment être jamais
dire professionnels pour faire du golf
que ça coûte très cher une activité qui
s'adresse aussi aux familles
exceptionnellement les plus petits
pouvaient faire leurs premiers pas sur
les terrains et apprendre les rudiments
de la petite balle blanche par respecter
la règle est le terrain le matériel est
juste jouer mettre la balle dans un trou
quant à babeth l'après-midi a suffi pour
trouver son swing
[Musique]
et on retrouve à présent nickel et demi
d'euros bonsoir je m'en sors analystes
sport de la rédaction vous nous faites
un panorama des résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département du football
pour commencer michael avec le
championnat de nationale 3 exactement
versailles à torcy c'était l'une des
affiches de cette sixième journée du
championnat de nationale 3 après une
première période équilibrée ponctuée par
un triste 0 à 0 les versailles et sont
plus entreprenants au retour des
vestiaires et arrive à trouver la faille
dans le dernier quart d'heure grâce un
doublé de benjamin louvet six fois
buteur en six matchs depuis le début de
la saison c'est pas mal un grégory
superbe le but versailles a parachevé sa
victoire grâce à johan akassou score
final 3 à 0 en écoute la réaction du
héros du jour
d'habitude nous de toujours bien
commencé commencé fort va réussir à
marquer dès le début on est on est coach
une vraiment une bonne équipe bien en
place
on a su être patient et franchement sur
la deuxième mi temps à mettre un petit
coup de folie pour
pour accélérer on a eu un petit peu de
chance aussi pas se mentir mais ça fait
partie du jeu aussi avec six victoires
en six matches 17 buts marqués 1 seul
but encaissé versées et réalise un début
de saison presque parfait des résultats
qui permettent aux joueurs de la cité
royale de faire cavalier seul en tête
avec déjà cinq points d'avancé sur le
paris fc on écoute l'entraîneur mais pas
d'esprit forcément parce que pouvoir
enchaîner autant de matches en étant
solide en refusant la défaite c'est que
les choses se passent entre les joueur à
l'état d'esprit le fait d'avoir un
objectif commun est de rester une
partition sur le terrain qui nous permet
d'avoir ce résultat prochain match pour
versailles ce dimanche 13 octobre sur le
terrain de courcouronnes en coupe de
france
une victoire et se serait dit il car
comme début de saison intègre et on va
suivre cette série voir si cette série
se poursuit on joue également toujours
c'est du football un mickaël le
championnat de régionale 2 on jouait une
journée de régionale 2 actes mantra pas
signé ce week-end sa première victoire
de la saison les trappistes promu cette
année sont allés s'imposer sur le score
de 3 à 0 sur le teint du cosmo taverne
une victoire qui leur permet de remonter
au classement et de ne plus être
lanterne rouge il se retrouve à la 10e
place sur 12 on écoute l'entraîneur de
l'équipe
ludovic gotti pour un mois de septembre
catastrophique on avait à coeur de
débuter le mois d'octobre par une
victoire et voilà c'est chose faite
j'espère que ça va lancer bonne
dynamique et et qu'on va pouvoir
enchaîner les bons résultats sur les
autres n'étaient pas encore vraiment une
équipe à trappes ya plein de bons
joueurs mais rejeté par une équipe et
hier on a été une équipe solidaire
déterminés à gagner à gagner l'autre
pour les mac
on termine par du basket michael trappe
se ressaisit dans ce championnat de
nationale 3 les trappistes se sont
imposés ce samedi soir sur leur terrain
contre like montivilliers 69 à 70 lors
de la 3e journée leur deuxième victoire
de la saison
un résultat qui leur permet d'être dans
le top 3 du championnat l'objectif du
club sera cette année à la montée après
l'avoir loupé de peu l'année dernière
merci michael pour ce tour d'horizon on
vous retrouve dans un instant l'émission
7,8 sport sur tv 78 il sera question
notamment
marche nordique sa soeur nordiques c'est
ça un rendez vous qui sera programmé à
versailles ce week-end ce dimanche il y
aura également parlera également du
rallye gazelle elle mène c'est un rallye
au maroc
vous verrez avec deux béliziens qui se
lancent dans l'aventuré et plus
d'informations dans votre 7,8 sport a
retrouvé donc après ce journal sur tv
78e allez vous échauffer et puis ce
samedi c'était la 18e nuits blanches
manifestation culturelle créée par la
ville de paris mais qui s'est exporté à
saint quentin en yvelines depuis deux
ans quatre lieux participait pour
l'occasion une soirée placée sous le
signe de la création artistique et de la
rencontre dans plusieurs disciplines
mélanie poker un nuage de quatre mètres
comme amuse bouche la création
prolifération de florence arnold était
la première découverte artistique de la
nuit blanche saint-quentinoise une
première participation pour la ville de
trappes quatre lieux se sont associés le
temps de cette soirée
ça nous permet de travailler avec
d'autres yeux de la communauté d'agglo
et d'avoir une vraie synergie ensemble
et ça c'est une vraie volonté qu'on a
entre le programmateur d'essayer d'avoir
des projets communs ils ont plus de
force comme ça pour cette nouvelle
édition les visites ont pu se faire en
circuit prochaine étape voisins le
bretonneux et sa biennale de la peinture
du coup ça permet de pas se brider de
bah justement d'avoir plusieurs
plusieurs lieux à visiter et à découvrir
avec des artistes m'ajouter
majoritairement de région parisienne qui
ont proposé des oeuvres qui ont été
sélectionnés et en l'honneur de la nuit
blanche on est à l'association soudja
qui nous a fait une création numérique
en fait comme des tableaux vivants qui
sont au milieu du hall et qui bouge
de temps en temps un circuit qui s'est
poursuivie à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt et la commanderie
le prochain grand rendez vous culturel
de l'agglomération débute le 7 novembre
la semaine des écrivains persécutés
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi retour dès demain pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]